president biden on friday announced to
his nominee to fill the supreme court's
seat of retiring justice stephen breyer
the president's selection of d.c circuit
court judge katanji brown jackson came
after a month's long search the white
house released video of the moment
president biden informed judge jackson
she is the first black woman to be
nominated to the supreme court ed
o'keefe is in wilmington delaware with
the president and has more on this
historic pick ed good morning to you
good morning jeff in making his
announcement the president makes good on
a campaign pledge to nominate a black
woman to the high court for the first
time now begins the confirmation fight
and the white house is hoping it goes
quickly
for too long
our government our courts haven't looked
like america
president biden's choice federal judge
katanji brown jackson was always
considered a frontrunner for the supreme
court nomination on friday the nation
began to learn why i am standing here
today by the grace of god as testament
to the love and support that i've
received from my family if confirmed
jackson would bring top-notch academic
and legal credentials and a unique life
story to the high court she graduated
with honors from harvard and harvard law
and clerked on the supreme court for
justice stephen breyer the man she's
poised to replace
jackson grew up in florida the daughter
of educators and in her high school
yearbook she wrote i want to eventually
have a judicial appointment
jackson would be the court's first
former federal public defender a job she
says has influenced her work as a judge
i take extra care to communicate
with the defendants who come before me
in the courtroom
she also comes from a family with a
unique perspective of law
and order you may have read
that i have one uncle who got caught up
in the drug trade and received a life
sentence that is true
but law enforcement also runs in my
family in addition to my brother i had
two uncles who served decades as police
officers one of whom
became the police chief
jackson acknowledged the history of her
nomination i can only hope that my life
and career
my love of this country and the
constitution
and my commitment to upholding the rule
of law and the sacred principles upon
which this great nation was founded
will inspire future generations of
americans
now cbs news has learned that jackson is
set to begin meeting with senators next
week and democrats who control the
senate are aiming to get her confirmed
by easter in mid-april whether she can
win any bipartisan support remains
unclear three republican senators voted
for her just last year to sit on the d.c
appeals court but all three of them said
on friday that the supreme court's
another matter and they will review her
record again before making a final
decision michelle
supreme court is another matter but it
is a matter of history and precedent
certainly is um thank you so much ed